hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the gray
eagle now we obviously saw this before
and I just realized I was carefully cut
by bomb okay we were carefully coming
through this plate before and I realized
that the handle that I was looking for
it didn't look like any other handle it
looked like this particular handle
because there was a hole in the wall in
the other room where I needed to go and
put this handle in the wall and then
crack the handle blah blah blah blah
blah I know what I needed to do and here
we go I know I didn't cheat I didn't I
know all you're like oh wait a minute no
I didn't Kurt Jahnke did I one dude out
one okay what did that do I don't even
remember why I was trying to do this in
the first place what was the deal what
was going on here what was the point of
all of this it's still really dark was I
turning on the elevator again but the
elevator was already on well what the
hell what was I doing
hey on hand yeah okay no one woman what
did that do I don't even remember why
whatever let's just follow the steam up
fleet
oh is that making noises there it is
again
who's making who's making noises oh yeah
this door oh I forgot okay Han squeaky
good chunk okay cool yeah we're moving
along doing something good for that
reason that I need to get that door open
well I don't look good haha that
majestic music is kind of out of place
with that red mist of doom loading level
change
oh no inner sanctuary okay not quite as
good as the inner sanctum but here we go
anyway woo nice nice relaxing music I'm
sure nothing bad will happen like with
the rest of this game oh wait a minute
this looks familiar it's a gray eagle
okay it's a great Eagle which is the
namesake of the game blah blah blah
there's only one door in this giant room
right huh well that's that's not very
helpful that's just a cave in area
finally some more gosh darnit oil you do
not want to give me much oil in this one
they gave me plenty of law down in them
and sanity potions but no oil this is
not even a little bit of a help so what
else is in this room that needs to be
found
um hello what was the point of that
there was nothing there was it was it
did I miss something like a switch on
the wall some sort of a thingy that I
can touch and wiggle and squiggle around
maybe rub all over maybe spread
something somewhere okay no look why ah
haha that can't have been it couldn't no
no no no no no there's got to be like
something if I stare long enough at the
Eagle give them the stink eye with my
error and then mash you know what what's
the point of this I don't see anything
else in this room I'm coming it very
carefully
there's nothing here what the hell well
what the hell what the flaming fook
that's bull that's bull honkey there was
nothing fair whatever now I'm back here
in the doomed of machinery area I didn't
even get a key maybe there was a key in
the chest that could have unlocked it
maybe hang on let me just double check
because a Kahneman in that couldn't ah
about a hall where the hog I'm up what
when was there a hole there
what I didn't see what cannot wait am i
oh okay I was just in pitch-black
darkness alrighty then this isn't normal
darkness this is advanced darkness I
haven't said that ten thousand times
before whoa grody alrighty then
oh that's not light of a torch uh nope
no light of all torches okay
well it sure is dark Oh lovely more dead
bodies animals things okay cam of that
some sorta more machinery weirdness what
is that
hahahaha ah [ __ ] you Kyle what was that
I don't even know it was red whatever
wasn't it had eyes stupid son of a [ __ ]
come at me bro thinking get me again the
bucket of tar why did I need a bucket of
fricken our lubricate this son of a
[ __ ] right is that a yes so yes thank
you thank you so much for your oil oh
thank you so much okay what is this
gaseous emissions dungeons butt hole
that is now farting in my face someone
said something to me recently that this
is a common thing we're siblings will
like pin want another one down and then
fart on their head is that a thing cuz I
had an argument with something like that
didn't have a thing me and my oh okay
well what's so special about that that's
like that's not a thing is it is it
what what was the point of that what did
that do
what oh you're joking me right I ice
what whoa whoa wait a move
what what what happened I lost the tar
did something actually do did I just
fill the other room with tar and now I
can go on my merry way what the hell
just happened
whoa whoa I'm so confused
I'm so confused I'm so confused what
just happened why did I use that tar on
that why why I don't know the perennial
question in these games
why okay oh there's some behind oh okay
I got it got a pipe and now that I've oh
oh they're gonna bite I can now that
it's thoroughly lubricated apparently
cuz that's a thing oh no no I don't Otto
it's this is correct this is correct you
can't tell me it's not I know this I
know this I know this is bowing out
open up open up you [ __ ] open your face
hole oh um gonna maybe Linnaean what is
that
woo uh why again why why am i doing
these things he's seemingly random tasks
ah yeah I'm out in the car you can't go
look at uh oh he was a [ __ ] I know
that poofing noise well whatever
what what the hell ah scratching my head
oh that commie is scratching well okay
you want me go back to the dungeons
butthole but why why damn it what do i
do what do i do ah man this would be a
lot easier if I wasn't so terribly
stupid so you just decided to do a
little dance there piggies dead-body
piggies okay
why are things randomly happening that
they shouldn't be happening it's go
ahead big giant head want to pop out at
me again no what the hell oh it got more
oil okay thank you thank you thank you
very much for your oil patronage okay so
yeah about that I yeah hi ow
wahoo aepb kiya I'm I'm stuck I'm stuck
is this breakable can I smash this down
is there like some crank on this
whatever it is why did I need to do this
do I drop something in here do I hammer
it real good like smash it real good I'm
at a loss
I'm out a couple okay let me just come
through this very meticulously I put
guitar in there so that I could fit the
pipe um when I put the pipe in the game
went from here to there is there any
other pipe that I could follow I can
maybe make it no can't open this door
coming up very carefully very carefully
move through this area looking for and
maybe throw barrel at it that house
that's the solution to many of life's
problems ah
no okay so jerk I got a itchy head I
don't know what died ignore my itchy
head it's nothing don't worry don't
worry about me
hey okay not turning into a monster
strange Gray Eagle infection that is
taking over my brain
hahaha I don't have a brain to infect
haha i full do stupid game thinking get
name okay I'm I'm so Domon so full of
not smartness juice
I couldn't possibly figure this out okay
what is what is what is all this
what's all this then what's all that oh
I'm so stupid
oh no damn I'm so dumb
I'm so dumb I fell I will travel out so
dumb oh no the switch I'll go be put the
cap back on it rare ha ha ha oh I
thought there's just rolling barrels I
thought they were done by me okay
alright nerman Kim in Slenderman doing
an interview maja what the hell that
come on tell me what happened the blob
walked up
what I've never heard that noise before
in my life by the way Oh weird okay I'm
gonna get it
why what happened who got me who got me
someone messing with me hello oh hi hi
its but number monsters hi hey buddy how
you doing
I haven't seen you in forever where's go
where'd you go where'd you go to little
buddies hello
oh you're gone am I so hideously ugly oh
they gave me food look they're so nice
oh is that it's not an artist depiction
of what they did to me when they bash my
brains out but haha game once again you
have been foiled
I have no brains to bash okay dude yes
you I'm talking to your silly prisoner
of dungeon I did watching you a long
time and how this glorious man has
managed to get into this hole anyway
down to business I've left your gift
there you did wisely there's something
in the bread hahaha
well that's really well hidden haha okay
just shushing does this is a sucessor
scissors sssss sssss so so so so that's
what's up anybody remember that no is
that before your time it's cuz you're
all like way younger than me and I'm
super old my internet references this is
a zoo zoo zoo zoo does is is it no one
knows that
okay nevermind I'm I'm just looking like
a fool whatever whatever don't matter at
least they left me my tinderboxes that's
what that's all I can really ask for oh
she's so peered hurt aful i'll try to go
for pretty and beautiful and it kind of
got mashed together yo - oh you're not
fine I'm in doofus okay whatever I don't
even have a lantern anymore so oh well
speak of the devil
all my oil ah
took all my oil again they're such dicks
why would they do that why would they do
that there's such [ __ ] I am freakin
Fraga whatever
chugalug a muggle look at her look okay
so we got some machinery here but no
switches that I can see well what's that
oh oh haha well done so uh what do I
need to do about that maybe there's
something there I must somehow knock it
down well I'm a good thrower of things
I'll throw this giant box no no Helena I
need to get something to throw Scoob a
boxer man how about you shut up and
fling up there
OOP what sorry about the [ __ ] throw ah
maybe I could climb I don't know hey
Becca climb up harridan okay that was
failed that was full of failure okay
then hi I'm a nibble on it with my teeth
oh I see something on top of it maybe I
don't ever saw any more late that some
[ __ ] well okay what the hell what well
get whatever I'm moving forward actually
I can move forward cuz I'm all out of
time so I will figure this out later and
sorry for the delay on this stupidity
there so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye
Oh
Benny's Bertha my gun
doing
she's really change it uppercut row